foreign
if you had to build a launch strategy
for the four hour work week in 2022
versus 20 2007.
otherwise known as 2007. what strategies
and channels would you employ which
strategies would stay consistent from
2007 and why
I think the the Crux decision which was
to
engage with people in person at events
at the time those were predominantly
bloggers now that might be different but
not necessarily blogs are still actually
a thing despite what people may think
but that core approach to taking the
uncrowded channel
of engaging with people in person at
events in recreational settings over
drinks would remain consistent and you
could remove every other
prong of the four hour work week launch
strategy
if I simply executed well again on that
type of in-person Engagement
I think the book would still be a
success today and to reiterate how I did
that or to give one example
I would
go to the after party after some
conference event where people are on
panels and sometimes I would approach
them afterwards very often when I would
approach a panel I would not approach
the panelists who are getting mobbed I
would approach the moderator who is
undeservedly neglected a lot of times in
cases like this and chat with the
moderator usually asking a handful of
follow-up questions which are sincere
questions about the topics on the panel
they would at some point generally ask
me well what are you doing here why are
you here and I would say it's my first
time at this event
I just finished writing my first book
it's this this and this it's based on
guest lectures I gave at Princeton
University from 200xt
2000 why and I'm trying to figure out
how to launch a book since it's really
on me the publisher effectively prints
and ships books I have to figure out how
to Market this
you know is there anyone you think I
might want to meet is there anyone you
think I might get along with and then
they would make a referral and I would
be on to the next referral and I would
repeat something like that each time
separately if I Came Upon say a group of
people bloggers let's just say I knew at
least one blogger was in this group
at a bar they'd be talking and I would
wander up and I would say something like
hey guys do you mind if I join in and
just listen in and they'd be like nah
whatever fine
and so I'd hang out and if I finished my
drink first I'd be like hey does anyone
else need a drink like don't be [ __ ]
weirdo just be a normal person but
anyway like hey does anyone else in your
drink I'm gonna grab another one okay
great get a couple drinks
and eventually somebody in the group
would be like so what's your story who
are you why are you here and I would
give some answer along the lines of what
I just mentioned and then I would just
stop I would not start pitching I would
not be I would not immediately start
humping their legs to ask them if they
wanted to read an advanced copy or
something like that but I would say that
and then I would I was sort of leave the
window open to more questions and then I
would see if anyone
took the bait and if they did that is an
indicator of at least I took it as an
indicator of Interest let's say one of
the people's like well okay so you said
your book is what's the book about and
then I would elaborate then maybe they
would ask some follow-up questions
and then at some point I would offer I
would simply say look it might not be of
any interest to you
I totally understand if you're just too
busy but there are I think maybe one or
two chapters that would be really
interesting to you if you'd like I mean
I have a ton of advanced copies I could
just send you a copy and put in some
Post-it notes for the 20 Pages or so
that I think would be most interesting
and I'd say
I don't know 60 70 of the time that I
went up to one of those groups at least
one person would be like yeah that
sounds cool yeah totally yeah please set
it and
that is a high labor approach that also
can have a very very high Roi
and
I would replicate that
I still think in person is the least
crowded it just takes a set of skills
that most people have neglected I think
in a world where everything is thought
to be digital and text first via email
the interpersonal piece I think gets
lost a bit in the
ability to navigate social dynamics in a
way that is
interesting but not
overwhelming or irritating takes
practice you got to practice this stuff
unfortunately I got a lot of practice
doing that on the phone and in person
in my first job out of college which was
being an outside sales rep
for fiber channel storage area networks
I had to
learn how to navigate this stuff so in
person still works or it can work